So this is this is actually very serious because
this could be this could be the start of a
ramp up of violence by Trump supporters as
we approach Inauguration Day for President
elect Joe Biden.
As I mentioned earlier, there was another
one of these million mega marches in DC this
weekend.
This time the Trump supporters, the proud
boys, the white supremacists, they were actually
starting to get violent, setting fires to
Black Lives Matter banners, including at churches,
getting into stabbing fights, multiple arrests.
We'll talk about it more on the bonus show.
But what I really want to focus on today is
not that part, because we'll get to that a
little bit later, but rather how this is all
part of a building Republican civil war between
factions of the right.
You've got the crazy right and the really
crazy right that are kind of battling.
And one of the chants that was heard this
weekend in Washington, D.C. at this march
was destroy the GOP, destroy the Republican
Party.
And the reasons that different Trump hosts
are mad at Republicans are numerous and wide
ranging.
It's actually funny.
Different elements of the Trump cult are mad
at the Republican Party or Republicans, but
for different reasons that sometimes conflict.
It's a comedy of errors, but one that could
have real repercussions over the next few
years and election cycles.
Some Trump hosts are mad at the Republican
Party because some Republican officials, like
Brian Camp in Georgia, haven't been willing
to overtly try to steal the election for Donald
Trump.
And they're furious at Brian Camp.
They're furious at Brad Raffensperger, the
secretary of state in Georgia and so on.
Others are mad at the Republican Party because
they're mad that the right wing Supreme Court
justices refused to hear a completely bogus
lawsuit about non-existent voter fraud.
So some of the ire is there.
And why don't you Republicans do more to hold
these people accountable?
Apparently not understanding how the Supreme
Court works.
Other Trump cultists are mad at Fox News because
they because Fox News acknowledges that Joe
Biden won at least during the daytime programing
on their network.
So this is interesting stuff.
Here is a guy introducing another guy named
Nick Fuentes, who's from one of these like
extra radical pro Trump wings of the right,
saying right wingers like Charlie Kirk and
Ben Shapiro essentially aren't radical enough.
And in fact, you know, now I'm questioning
I don't know if Nick Ventus is still part
of a pro Trump.
Right.
Or if they've separated.
It's a complete and total mess.
But listen to what was said here.
I believe in America first started the first.
So now Ben Shapiro is too far left, I guess
partially because Ben Shapiro was anti Trump.
It's initially, even though Ben Shapiro voted
for Trump and then outcomes Nick Ventus himself.
And he gets to destroy the Republican Party
chant going.
And the first billion dollars of our tweet
promised that if the GOP would not do everything
in their power to Trump in office, then we
would destroy the GOP.
In Washington, D.C., for a second billion
budget, but we're kind of making promises
in house to house and now we are going to
destroy the GOP.
So, of course, in thinking about the future
of the Republican Party, there is like an
actual academic discourse to be had about
the future of the two party system and the
future of the Republican Party within that
and changing demographics and how that might
influence things and gerrymandering and redistricting.
But then there's sort of like this other question
mark, which is if Trump remains really visible
after leaving office, that will have a very
different effect on these subgroups in the
Republican Party.
Then if Trump disappears from view and we
won't know that for a few weeks, there could
be a big reconciliation among the right.
And all of these elements come back together.
It's you know, this is not an irreversible
grudge that we are seeing.
If Trump leaves, all of these groups may quickly
realize, hey, what we really hate is the left
and they'll be back together in no time.
On the other hand, if Donald Trump remains
visible once he's out of office and continues
weaponize the cultists against other aspects
of the Republican Party, this can continue
for some time.
Remember what Lindsey Graham said?
I guess it was four or five years ago.
Now, if we nominate Trump, we will get destroyed
and we will deserve it.
May be loony.
Lindsey really was on to something there.
And it would be great if this did end up throwing
the Republican Party into such chaos that
they implode for a few election cycles.
I do think we should encourage it.
I mean, why not foment the feeling when you're
talking to traditional Republicans that these
Trump ists are making them look insane?
And then when you're talking to the Trump
is foment the idea that these traditional
Republicans clearly aren't committed to their
movement and they've betrayed them on this
election issue?
I think it's an absolutely great idea.
But to really know what the future of this
is going to be, we have to see what happens
after the Biden inauguration.
How visible does Trump remain and sort of
go from there?
I don't think we'll really know whether the
Republican Party is gearing up for a sustained
civil war until it's more clear what role,
if any, Trump will have within the Republican
Party after January 20th.
So we will wait for that.
And after the break, I will tell you all about
what is taking place today to make that inauguration
of Joe Biden an inevitable reality via the
official vote of the Electoral College The
David Pakman Show at David Pakman Duchon.
The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman Dotcom.